so
stalin held power for 30 years
uh vladimir putin has held power for
21 years we could argue he took a little
break
uh but not much he was still holding
power i think
and it's still possible now with the new
uh
uh constitution that he could hold power
from longer than stalin 30
longer than 30 years what do you think
about the man
the state of affairs in russia
in general the system they have there
is there something interesting to you as
an economist as a human being
about russia everything is interesting i
mean he would be
part of my take as you know the russian
economy
starting what 1999 2000 has really quite
a few years
of super excellent growth and putin is
still
riding on that it more or less coincides
with his rise as the truly focal figure
on the scene since then pretty recently
they've had a bunch of years of negative
four to five percent growth in a row
which is
terrible the economy is way too
dependent on fossil fuels
but the structural problem is this you
need a concordance
across economic power social power
political power
they don't have to be allocated
identically but they have to be
allocated
consistently and the russian system
under putin from almost the beginning
has never been able to have that
that ultimately his incentives are to
steer the system where the economic
power
is in a small number of hands in a
non-diversified way
the system won't deliver sustainable
gains and living standards
anymore ever the way it's set up now
that with fossil fuel prices go up
they'll have some good years for sure
and that is really quite structural what
has gone wrong
and then on top of that you can have an
opinion of putin but you've got to start
with those structural problems and
that's why it's just
not going to work but he had all those
good years in the beginning
so the number of russians say who live
here or in russia
who love putin and it's sincere they're
not just afraid of being you know
dragged away
like that's a real phenomenon uh yeah
i'm really torn on
you know putin's approval rating real
approval rating
seems to be very high and i'm torn
in whether that's has to do with uh
the fact that there is uh control of the
press
or if it's which is the people i talk to
who are in russia family and so on
a genuine love of putin appreciation of
what putin has done and is going to do
with russia
and a lot of that would go away if the
press were freer i think
yes well singapore realizes this anyone
discussed by the press
no matter who they are people in
singapore have done a great job
yes uh but if you're discussed by the
press you don't look good
take company executives are learning
this right it's just like a rule
so in that sense i think the rating is
artificially high but i don't
by any means think it's all insincere
but that high popularity i view as
bearish for russia
i would feel better about the country if
people were more pissed off at him
yeah that's right it's nice to see free
speech even if it's
full of hate
you